regardez bien cette vente car chantier
interdit au public et bien ici c'est à
moitié vrai suivez-moi
op stand christelle pourquoi chantier
interdit au public
et quand je dis que c'est pas tout à
fait vrai c'est parce que ce gentil du
château d'azay-le-rideau naïs visite
il se visite 1 grâce à un espace
d'introduction à la visite qui explique
véritablement on les techniques les
métiers toutes les compétences qui sont
nécessaires pour restaurer un château
comme azay-le-rideau qui est un château
classé monument historique a alors
c'était un peu à concevable de dire que
pendant une saison touristique
plusieurs mains parce que ça va durer
plusieurs années de fermer château c'est
inconcevable c'est ça alors c'était
inconcevable mais en plus le défi pour
le centre des monuments nationaux
c'était véritablement de montrer les
coulisses la chantier de restauration
s'intéresse à beaucoup de gens
c'est un château ce qui va bientôt fêter
ses cinq cents ans de vie à cent ans ce
n'est pas rien dans l'histoire d'un
monument et on parle même du chantier du
siècle puisque les travaux que nous
sommes en train de faire actuellement
sur ce château ne se compare fait avant
150 ans voilà alors quand on regarde le
château c'est vrai c'est vrai il ya
quand même des choses à travailler on
voit ses grilles sur les toits ya de la
mousse et les lichens
il ya des halles c'était ça
alors complètement vous avez raison en
effet le tuffeau est une pierre blanche
c'est une pierre calcaire qui est
extrêmement fragile et ici on voit
totalement les intempéries liées au
temps aux années de vie du château
on a des mousses des lichens des algues
qui font que l'épiderme de la pierre est
très altérée et puis quand on regarde
d'un peu plus près la toiture on
s'aperçoit aussi qu'on a encore des
moussan et des lichens et puis cette
voiture elle a été faite il ya 150 ans
alors ton tout ça il ya un architecte
oui monuments historiques on l'a
rencontré il va un peu nous expliquer et
bien tout ce qu'est ce champion 75
tonnes dardoise 30 tonnes d'échafaudage
152 mètres cubes de pierres 4125 mètres
carrés de pia de surface 35 mètres
carrés de chêne neuf des chiffres
exceptionnels pour un chantier
d'exception
seul un architecte en chef des monuments
historiques devaient affronter le
pharaonique projet et en plus il fallait
faire un choix dans la méthode on a
hésité effectivement à reprendre les
couvertures par parti comme ça a été
fait depuis depuis 50 ans où s'entend et
on s'aperçoit que c'est très néfaste
puisque on avait des tas de modèles
d'ardoyne différentes d'irak lors qu'ils
fuyaient et caetera et là on a eu la
chance de pouvoir monter m'appelle un
grand échafaudage un parapluie qui
couvre l'ensemble donc ça permet d'une
part de faire des travaux dans une bonne
condition dû faire complètement et d
assurer la pérennité de l'ensemble
ce château que l'on dit féminin est en
quelques sortes un institut de beauté
une beauté dont il faut effectivement
prendre grand soin charpente couverture
façade la restauration se fera toutefois
en deux étapes les matériaux et les
entreprises sont de la région ou du
département limitrophe à l'exception des
armes
les ardoises
malheureusement il n'y a plus de grandes
ardoises bière en france puisque c'est
le danger tout est très connue ont fermé
il ya quelques années et donc le choix
s'est fait sur des heures d espagne
après un appel d'offres et d un cahier
des charges très précis ce qui fait qu
évidemment on a sélectionné une qualité
dardoise en exigeant aussi d'ailleurs
qu'il ya une traçabilité cercle on va
vérifier au fur et à mesure du
déroulement du chantier que c'est bien
la même angoisse que l'on a sélectionné
mêmes qualités de résistance pour être
sûr que l'ensemble soit de bonne qualité
et puissent résister dans le temps toute
la restauration fera l'objet d'un
archivage exceptionnelle pour les années
futures
pendant les travaux la visite continue
et azéri dont retrouvera toute sa
superbe fin 2017
la prochaine restauration est prévue
elle dans 150 ans et là maintenant que
c'est bien nous sommes à l'intérieur du
château parce que tout l'intérieur se
visite extérieure qui est en travaux
christelle lorsque je disais tout à
l'heure château féminin je crois que là
où nous sommes on peut pas mieux qu'on
ne sait exactement on est dans la
chambre de philippe lhez bailly qui est
l épouse de gilles berthelot gilles
berthelot et est donc conseiller
financier auprès de françois 1er et on
écrit dans les livres d'histoire qu'il a
construit le château d'azay-le-rideau en
fait ce château a été entièrement
construit par son épouse philippe laisse
veille quand on étudie les registres de
compte de la construction entre 418 etc
1 124 ce château et ayant été construit
en six ans ce qui est extrêmement court
avec une centaine d'ouvriers en
permanence
eh bien on s'aperçoit en fait que madame
l'esbva y avait la mainmise totale sur
les travaux bon on s'en va découvrir une
autre pièce avec vous les ir
on y va donner alors ce qu'il y à bien
dans ce château
christelle c'était on va s'asseoir à la
table de jeu c'est que de pièce en pièce
on voyage à travers les siècles
il a on se retrouve on va dire dans la
salle l'intimité en quelque sorte des
derniers propriétaires
oui on est dans le salon des marquis de
billancourt qui ont été propriétaires du
château pendant un siècle de 1791 à 1901
et les tailles devenu propriétaire en
1905 est bien court tenait à ce que le
château puisse présenter une renaissance
rêver une renaissance idea leader
magnifier ce le promets choteau de
france que toulouse dès les années 1850
on peut visiter le château alors bien
entendu à cette époque c'est un tourisme
un peu particulier un tourisme constitué
d'aristocrates c'est d'être le voit
faire kristen je me suis bien se
retrouver demain d'accord avec plaisir
un fragment à demain denis le 19/20
continue dans un instant avec le journal
de la rédaction nationale bonne soirée à
vous et à demain donc